the holy war begins that is the subject
of this evenings Talking Points Memo
Isis has made this a holy war they're
going after these cops because they're
Christian no one is safe what we're
seeing unfolding before us in the Middle
East is genocide they're coming folks
and if they are not stopped what you saw
in Libya could happen outside your local
church the White House refuses to call
the enemy Islamic terrorists and get
this they won't call the beheaded
Egyptians Christians it was another
weekend of bloodletting by the radical
followers of Muhammad the Muslims called
the video a message signed with blood to
the people of the cross if Fox didn't
talk about this they have nothing else
to talk about it would seem to me their
Islamic extremists in all nine is
Christian extremists monstrous Islamic
jihadist Islamic terrorists killing
innocent people radical Islam Islamic
extremism I'm not sure an awful lot is
gained by by saying
the holy war is here and unfortunately
it seems the president of the United
States will be the last one to
acknowledge it also made waves with his
speech at the National Prayer Breakfast
when he spoke of Isis and then issued
these words of warning to Christian